Now the relationship between the variables in the candy machine situation we
just talked about is of a special type, it's called a function. Now some more
strictly mathematical examples of functions are things like I've written right
here. Y equals negative 2 x plus 5. Y equals x squared plus 5 x plus 6. Y equals
negative 5. There are ton of other ones. Pretty much all of the equations for
lines and problems that you've seen in this course are functions. We just
haven't been using this word yet. Now, however it is time. Think back to the
relationship between the input and output in the gumball examples from the last
quiz. And then please complete this sentence here for me. If we consider x to be
the input and y to be in the output of some function. Then there is no more than
one value of, what for a given value of what. Remember again, how you answered
the similar question for the candy example. You can also, of course, look at
values of x and y that satisfy each of these equations, or you can graph them to
figure this out.